The jogan Experience oh karate balls of
the feet I'm at karate is uh
underrated dude can you
imagine [__] oh Jesus oh Jesus oh Jesus
he's out oh my God what the f Cal God he
kicked oh my God oh my God he head
kicked now you'll never see that fight
again that's the risk that's the risk
God what a shock wow what a shocker you
still we're even now God damn he head
kicked him tough who would have saw that
com Miss I didn't even see it it was
amazing Shin to the Dome son opened up a
cut it was perfect D damn wow damn Islam
man he he showed a bunch of new [__]
that front kick and he was throwing that
kick to the body and then he threw the
same kick to the Head yeah and taking on
10 days notice you you worry about his
cardio going the later rounds but this
one you know it is what it is it's a
legit win oh it's a solid win man the
way it went down I mean they this was
not this was not he was tired this not
unprepared no he got caught y he got
caught he got caught with an amazing
that would happened with a 12we camp
10day Camp it very well could have very
well could have very well could have I
mean what he what he did look at that
dude they [__] love each other look
at that [__] he saved the at that
[__] what does he say stop sto the war
good for him good for him yeah two
different Muslims came up and said that
good for them man [__] for them need
more of that that's awesome good for
them but both Fighters hamzad and him
said the same thing yep good for them
Class Acts these people are just well
makev is definitely a Class Act yeah I'm
just so impressed that he won that way
this the fact that he I mean he showed
so much improvement he really made
adjustments cuz they must have trained
for volkanovski again even though he
wasn't fighting volkanovski I'm sure
they went over all the different things
that vonsky did and what are the
counters to those things and he shut a
lot of it down he shut down that switch
kick to the outside leg throwing that
front kick up the middle set up the head
kick I agree see how he's ducking down
yeah you're right yeah set it up dude
that was just set it up that was the
adjustment by the way baseball bat
through that [__]
that was the adjustment front kicks it
kind of looked like it was going to the
body from the placement of the knee in
the beginning if you're looking at from
the side it was just perfect perfect
head
kick I mean he's just look he knocked
down Oliva in the last fight remember
his striking was his weakest point and
now it's [__] dangerous as anybody in
the division you knock out Vulcan Ali
[__]
very
classy so if they give us pra 60-day
suspension Not only was it classy but
you know some people go extra classy
just to scene classy he just to to me
that was just him just being honest with
reality
MH and it was beautiful beautiful it was
beautiful it was like listen my job done
here I'm going back down let me keep me
busy I don't I just want to keep working
he didn't say I want to rematch when I
don't have 10 days notice this is
[__] none of that I hate when guys
do that was like that INF fighting they
go if this was a real fight I'd win it's
like yeah but it's not you signed up for
this